est avec aurélien véron par téléphone
conseiller de paris élu du mouvement
paris centre qui rassemble aussi des
républicains et des libéraux bonsoir
olivier sderot bonsoir mr aujourd'hui
paris avec le raf de datsyuk l'absolu
mans merci de la précision merci d'être
avec nous en direct
tout d'abord votre réactions d'élus de
la ville de paris justement à cette
nouvelle attaque
pour commencer j'ai une pensée pour les
victimes qui semble heureusement hors de
danger
et puis pour tous les habitants qui ont
été à nouveau réveillée dans leurs pires
souvenirs des de l'année 2015 et qui
revivre le cauchemar
donc je le crois que les forces de
l'ordre aussi doit être saluée dans leur
intervention rapide avec beaucoup de
sang froid
je crois qu'il faut rappeler dans cet
événement la france est un pays libre
cette liberté on inscrit au fronton de
tous nos bâtiments publics
c'est la première valeur de notre trio
liberté égalité fraternité
cette liberté nous ne renoncerons jamais
le premier message adressé aux
terroristes islamistes qui viennent
tester notre capacité de résistance et
c'est chez nous terroriser c'est que
nous ne ferons jamais sur la liberté
notre soutien à la presse libre même si
cette presslib lougratte nous irrite
perry cathodique on était très
embarrassée par parler dont les
musulmans des juifs tous les gens qui
ont du king fondation des fois se sont
fait se sentent hésité de temps en temps
par les interventions de charlie hebdo
nous devons un assemblement défendre la
liberté de la presse aussi des airs et
un soit elle pour nos conditions parfois
ça fait partie de la france et la france
et ça fait ce sont hier tous unis face à
la barbarie quoi faire demain puisqu'il
s'agit pas non plus de marques une
pensée on implique il va réagir et des
mesures qui sont prises moi je jette
l'opprobe sur personne je veux pas
hurler à al gouvernement et dire qu'il
n'a rien fait les magistrats la police
les services de pénitentiaire ya des
trapézistes y sont qui évoluent elles
évoluent porte peut-être trop lentement
notre goût on aimerait qu'elle aille un
peu plus vite la question de la police
municipale à paris va se poser veut
croire ça ça doit être un rappel que
tout police municipale dans une ville
comme paris doit être armés parce que
être confrontés ou risquent d'être
confrontées à ce genre de menaces et
agression au hachoir à la
machete avec des armes blanches voir des
armes à feu on ne peut pas envoyer des
policiers eurent marqué police dans le
dos municipaux ils soient pas outillés
pour y poster ou en tout cas se défendre
on va vous faire de la luge
allez-y franprix a lésé je vous en prie
poursuivaient et puis la stratégie de
lutte contre l'islamisme rien coûté à
elle trois ans beaucoup de visages je
croise à ce que dans l'ombre pour pas
justement révélé les techniques à ses
partisans parfois isolés ceux là ont
l'air particulièrement isolé il y en a
un des deux le pré il n'était pas
inscrit au fichier s dont ils et elles
ont identifié d'autres sont suivis dans
une dizaine de milliers bah il ya des
techniques on teste les clubs de sport
était en ce moment on sait dans certains
clubs de sport tous les milieux sociaux
où il est des rencontres
il ya des tentatives de de faire d'eux
de détecter des personnalités un peu
faible de les recruter que d'en faire
des bombes vivantes
donc voilà il faut continuer et
accélérer insisté il a pas seulement une
question de moyens mais qui sont aussi
de stratégie c'est pas simple il ya un
rapport sénatorial sorti il ya deux ans
qui décrit très bien ce à quoi on est
confronté car c'est une guerre complexe
et donc je vois le compte que sur l'état
pour continuer à mettre des moyens et à
développer cette stratégie évolutive
face à un virus
parce que c'est un virus mortel 7,7 ce
djihadisme un v8 évolué dix minutes et
bien nous aussi à nos forces de lutte et
de suivre l'évolution et d'être de plus
en plus vigilantes non une enquête est
en cours il ya effectivement ce procès
qui se tient actuellement des coupables
de l'attentât de charlie hebdo elle ce
lieu aussi symbolique de la tacc pour
vous ça ne peut être qu'une qu'une
réponse qu'une riposte ce qui est en
train de se passer au tribunal
aujourd'hui c'est une riposte
heureusement de d'amateurs qui n'ont pas
à préparer leur pouls convenablement
parce que les faire quoi chiffres c'est
autre chose que les deux personnes qu'on
a eu tout à l'heure heureusement
heureusement et j'espère que les
prochaines heures et prochains jours le
confirmait n'ya de desseilles à 2 2 deux
victimes mortelles martens
donc c'est déjà ça mais effectivement il
ya eu il ya un symbole et ses symboles
sont importants il faut les défendre il
faut s'y tenir pour résister il faut pas
lâcher un centime de terrain face à
cette tentative d'intimidation de la
france il y avait un contexte
assez délicat avec ce procès il y avait
aussi cette drh de charlie hebdo qui a
dû être évacué de son domicile en moins
de dix minutes parce qu'elle était
menacée
le renseignement pour vous a fait at-il
fait défaut écoutez je ne suis pas dans
le renseignement j'ose espérer que les
personnes les tout l'encadrement du
renseignement en fait le maximum et on a
quand même à faire je rappelle à un
virus qui mute un des deux agresseurs
aujourd'hui n'était pas dans les
fichiers s il avait jamais rien fait
jusqu'ici et tout d'un coup il bascule
donc cette bascule elle est pas évidente
à anticiper je vois je crois qu'il soit
arrivé à suivre convenablement les dix
ont mis le fichier est sous 9,19
fichiers et puis avoir des méthodes
prédictive
mais il n'y a pas de méthode magique on
le retrouve et sinon et on n'est pas les
seuls rappelle que les attentats la
france est particulièrement frappé un
froid qu'on écrit un pays enfin d'autres
pays en europe et dans le monde réel ont
été atteints il n'y a pas de méthode
magique
il ya une stratégie qui se déploie qui
évolue qui s'adapte il ya des profils
nouveaux qui viennent tous les jours il
ya le plus jeune avait 18 ans main 18
ans c'est pas évident d'avoir des
signaux de d'antécédents donc où le non
jeu je crois le renseignement est un peu
outillés je veux trois suppléments ici
et maintenant au gouvernement de
continuer à mettre la pression à mettre
des moyens au service de cette chasse de
cette lutte constante
oui réhaussé peut-être le niveau d'
alerte attentats dans ce contexte de
procède des attentats de charlie hebdo
oui peut-être que je pense que le je
pense que le niveau de l'est était déjà
élevée dans les services de
renseignement il allait et puis la
lecture de des témoignages pendant ce
procès des témoignages très soignée on
était moyen âge bouleversant évidemment
suscite deux parmi les faiseurs de haine
et c'est ces terroristes
longvic de passer à l'acte à nouveau oui
je crois que c'était déjà sous
surveillance mais encore une fois on a
des profils qui sont atypiques et qui
encore une fois rates ton en dessous
d'assassiner il n'arrive pas assassiné
c'est déjà la preuve qu' on a beaucoup
affaibli cette gangrène est juste à
servir le ministre le ministre à l'effet
qu'ils avaient des risques d'attentats
en ce moment il ya une alerte a
récemment
les informations étaient déjà remontés
il ya des signaux dont je crois que le
niveau d' alerte il est dû arriver
dernière question aurélien véron la
réaction des parisiens les classes qui
ont été confinés pendant pendant tout le
périmètre de sécurité qui a été imposée
les français maintenance à faire face à
ce type de situation je n'étais pas sur
le terrain pendant cette mobilisation
j'ai eu le sentiment par les retours que
cet effet dont deux avec beaucoup de
sang-froid d'efficacité et finalement il
ya un traumatisme et de trauma ressort
mais on prend des décisions vite bien et
les maires parisiens ont agi tout à fait
de manière rapide réactiver et
responsable
merci beaucoup aurélien véron d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en direct sur
arte france